so how do you prepare yourself mentally
to be an entrepreneur
so what i will say is maybe borrowing a
little bit from from buddhism or or
philosophical hinduism
but it's really this notion to
try to not get attached to the outcome
obviously you're going into
entrepreneurship because you're
imagining that one you could be your own
boss you'll be able to
apply your creative ideas you'll be able
to do a service for the world but it's
good to go into it with a bit of a zen
philosophy where you're going to do
what's right you're going to do what's
in service of the customer or the user
or whoever you are whoever you are
serving
but you're not going to define your self
based on
how successful you are are you not
because
what typically happens in
entrepreneurship is that you start with
this optimism and i that's where i
started to do it it's it's almost
delusional or sometimes can be and you
might quit your job and then you go into
it and you quickly realize that the
world doesn't immediately come to
recognize the brilliance of what you
might be of what you might be working on
and so there will likely be a period
where you'll really question yourself uh
you'll be looking at your finances
you'll be depleting your finances and
it's all that much worse if your ego is
heavily invested in that as well if you
say what will people think of me what is
going to happen to my career i'm not
going to afford the lifestyle that i'm
used to
but if you
suppress your ego a little bit and say
i'm doing this for the good of the world
whether it's for-profit nonprofit
whatever it is i'm doing it in service
to others
and i'm doing what's right
and hopefully we'll have a good outcome
but you're not super attached to it then
it's going to lower the anxiety level i
heard a quote recently that anxiety is
misplaced
and you know i think most entrepreneurs
or aspiring entrepreneurs one thing they
have a surplus of is imagination and
that's a great thing but sometimes your
imagination can get into cycles of all
of the bad things that will happen or or
how people will think of you etc etc so
i would try not to go there
and if you do that i think you'll just
be more resilient because a lot of
entrepreneurial ideas it's not a a
matter of whether it's a good idea or
not it's not a matter of even
whether you're executing well or not you
do need to execute well but sometimes
it's a matter of timing and the more
resilient you can make yourself
also the more resilient you can make
your business so making yourself
resilient we're talking about mental
resilience you can make yourself
financially resilient by living below
your means having a lot of savings and
you can make your business financially
resilient so that it can hit the timing
at the right time or have more time to
be able to for the market to recognize
its value
if you do it in a very lean way and if
you're always taking new data points
and processing it and that's the other
place where it's good to suppress your
ego because sometimes early on you get
so enamored with an idea that even if
some data points even if some
research even if some customers are
telling you that that's not exactly what
they want
your confirmation bias almost like well
i'm talking to the wrong people or that
data might not be right maybe that's the
case but i think the less that you have
your ego super invested in your idea
that it's your idea the more that you'll
be willing to pivot and the more that
you're willing to change you know
famously in the early days of khan
academy when i was working on all the
software i showed it to a friend and he
suggested i make videos to supplement
the software and i immediately thought
it was a horrible idea but it took a
little bit of my ego suppression to
realize that you know just because i
didn't think of it doesn't mean it's a
bad idea and just because other people
had done it didn't mean it doesn't mean
it was a bad idea so i said let me try
it out and there was a unique take on
how i was doing it to complement the
software that that very nascent khan
academy was doing
that that really helped
us get off the ground
so what i would say is become resilient
a lot of that is being aware of your ego
you don't have to destroy your ego but
know it's there
and you have to put it in its place
every now and then
always be open to new data make yourself
financially and mentally resilient and
do the same for your organization or
your nascent organization that you're
starting